- Karen, I love your accent.
I'm gonna be real with you,
I thought you were American.
(laughter)
- Did you? I'm gonna take
that as a compliment.
Because I'm always
pretending to be American.
- Well you do a really good job.
- [Karen] Thank you.
- Yeah, you like, Christian Bale-d me,
like I had no idea he was English.
(laughter)
I had no idea.
No, it's amazing, but I've actually worked
with a couple Scots, and they all have...
- Oh, have you?
- Yes, and it's like, "Alan,"
that's what they say, "Alan."
- Aye, that's a typical name.
- Anyway, he always used to
say these Scottish phrases,
that like never, I was
like, "That's not English."
Like, but it like, was English.
- And you're pretty much right.
(laughter)
- Like, can you have any?
Do you know any?
- Okay, should we play a little game?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Where I say a Scottish phrase,
and you have to guess what it means?
- Yeah, go for it, I love this.
- Okay, ready for the first one?
She's up the heid, oan.
- [Kelly] What?
- She's up the heid oan
- She's up there heid oan
(laughter)
- Not Idaho!
- [Kelly] She's high,
so what is she doing?
- She's freaking out.
- She's up to heid oan!
- No that's not like
- Yeah in America when your heid oan
- I was like, yeah no
(laughter)
- Shall I do another one?
- Do another one!
- Okay.
Dinna fash yourself
- What?
- Say that one more time
- Dinna fash yourself!
- Dinna fash yourself who?
- He does a good Scottish accent
(all speaking at once)
- He's an actor, I'm a
singer, this is not fair!
- I'm sorry you're a singer
(laughing)
- [Sterling] What's it mean?
- It means don't worry.
- What did you say again?
- Don't worry
- No but say the first thing
(uproarious laughter)
- I lost my earring!
I just lost my earring!
I said don't worry!
(laughter)
Oh!
I totally lost my earring.
I don't know where it went!
You're so kind!
I'll just hold it here.
- Take that, don't lose it again!
(audience laughter)
- The only Scottish I know is
wasn't it Scotty on
Star Trek or something.
"Call the captain, yeah,
gonna need more power.)
- He was like a comedian or something.
- Oh sure and not Scottish at all
- Fake accent
- Are you serious? I
thought he was Scottish!
- Way to go, talented people!